when i pancakes and steak i cut them up  entirely before i eat them don't you do  that entirely entirely you know it's  because you're bouncing it's out of time  hell no chuck that's the it cuts all the  meat up so it's also that's ridiculous  yeah so it's all getting cold  chuck first of all my meal i mean too  fast for it to get cold let's get that  out the way  i have a few questions about what i  heard you said do you eat your chicken  huh my flappers yes  don't say it  i didn't hear it just heard it just i  didn't hear it don't say it i'm not  gonna say it again okay and you do what  with your gum i swallowed my gum all  right cool  you're good with that  all right here's what's happening  double header coming your way stop  boston